August might seem like a slow month for
movies but that doesn't mean there isn't
plenty of entertainment available one of
the best ways to wind down the summer is
by watching trailers for what's ahead
glimpses of the horror romance action
and drama that's set to arrive in
theaters over the coming months here are
all the August trailers that are
guaranteed to blow you away
mother written and directed by darren
aronofsky mother stars Jennifer Lawrence
and Javier Bardem as a couple whose
peaceful existence is disturbed when
guests show up in their home a simple
premise that as the trailer suggests may
not actually be so simple the trailer
offers a thrilling and terrifying
glimpse at Aronofsky's newest attempt to
mess with our heads
featuring creepy imagery along with
deeper hints at the film's disturbing
plot sign us up for whatever nightmares
mother has to offer the wild wedding
basically the main thing you need to
know about the wild wedding is that
Patrick Stewart has hair but the rest of
it looks pretty good too
Stewart plays Harold a writer preparing
to marry retired film star Eve played by
Glenn Close the guests at their wedding
include John Malkovich's Eve's
ex-husband as well as many driver grace
Van Patten oranges the new blacks Yael
stone and the Americans Noah Emmerich
chewing gum / Arnold Schwarzenegger is
the most feared hitman in the business
in the upcoming action comedy killing
Gunther written and directed by Saturday
Night Live veteran Taran Killam
Schwarzenegger stars as Gunther who
becomes the target of an assassination
plot from his fellow hitman killings
directorial debut seems both stylish and
funny and Schwarzenegger while only
appearing briefly in the trailer looks
great in his role as a ridiculously
skilled assassin mark felt the man who
brought down the White House Liam Neeson
plays deep throat in the true story of
Mark felt an FBI agent who became the
Watergate whistleblower for Washington
Post reporters Bob Woodward and Carl
Bernstein the talented cast is rounded
out by Diane Lane Tony Goldwyn Josh
Lucas and Michael C Hall literally right
before Erin Justin Long stars in
literally right before Aaron as Adam a
man still reeling from his recent
breakup when his ex-girlfriend calls to
let him know she's getting married Adam
agrees to go to the wedding and
predictably things quickly take a turn
for the worse
the Florida Project Shawn Baker's
tangerine follow up the Florida Project
has all the heart and beauty shown in
his early
your work albeit in a new setting this
time Baker investigates the lives of
those living in an extended stay motel
in Orlando focusing specifically on a
precocious six-year-old and the motels
owner Bobby played by Willem Dafoe Dafoe
is the grounding force of the trailer
but the child actors are given the
chance to shine as well already enjoying
rave reviews the florida project looks
like a beautiful touching exploration of
childhood we're all in cellblock 99 it's
Vince Vaughn like you've never seen him
before in the trailer for brawl and
cellblock 99 the latest action outing
from bone tomahawk director s Craig
dollar bond plays Bradley Thomas a
former boxer who resorts to drug running
in an effort to save his marriage after
losing his job as a mechanic things
quickly go wrong when a drug deal turns
deadly putting him behind bars goodbye
Christopher Robin the new trailer for
goodbye Christopher Robin stars domhnall
gleeson is a a Milne the author who
dreamed up we need the Pooh for his
young son Christopher Robin margot
robbie takes on the part of mills wife
Daphne in the film the trailer deals
heavily with Milne struggle with PTSD
but manages to balance drama humor and
heart in a way that will hopefully
translate into an effecting biopic
Batman vs two-face Adam West's final
performances Batman is teased in the
trailer for Batman vs two-face the
Batman legend reprised his role
alongside Burt Ward's Robin with the two
facing off against Harvey Dent voiced by
William Shatner in the sequel to 2016 s
Batman return of the Caped Crusader's
suburbicon directed by George Clooney
from a script co-written by the Coen
brothers suburbicon stars Matt Damon as
Gardner Lodge a man dealing with the
violent advances of a loan shark in his
small 1950s era American town Oscar
Isaac and Julianne Moore co-star and
with so many huge names attached it
looks like suburbicon is a town
audiences won't want to leave even if
the residents most definitely do last
flag flying break out the tissues before
you watch the trailer for Richard
Linklater's last flag flying
Steve Carell leads the drama D as
Richard doc said who recruits two of his
Vietnam buddies played by Brian Cranston
and Laurence Fishburne to help him bury
his son after he's killed in Iraq the
three leads have great chemistry and
they're growing bond helps anchor what
looks like an emotional cross-country
journey death wish Bruce Willis is out
for vigilante justice in the first
trailer for Eli
Deathwish a remake of the 1974 film of
the same name the movie follows Willis's
Paul Kersey a doctor who seeks revenge
after the violence in the streets of
Chicago spills into his own home while
remakes are old had at this point death
wish looks like it could be worth a trip
to the theater mollies game Jessica
Chastain stars as the smart
straight-talking Molly bloom in the
first trailer for Aaron Sorkin's
directorial debut Molly's game which
tells the true story of the
olympic-class skier who ran an exclusive
high-stakes poker game as the trailer
shows the movie follows Molly on her way
up in the poker world while also showing
her downfall
Chastain also has some impressive back
up in the movie with co-stars Idris Elba
and Michael Cera call me by your name
this Film Festival darling stars Armie
Hammer as Oliver an American professor
who travels to northern Italy in the
summer of 1983 while there he falls into
a relationship with a 17-year old
Italian boy with an early 100% on Rotten
Tomatoes call me by your name clearly
isn't a movie you want to miss super
troopers - it's been a long long time
coming but the first trailer for the
upcoming Super Troopers 2 is finally
here and it's awesome the sequel to the
cult cop comedy features the group of
Vermont State Troopers fighting with
Canada over the borderline setting up a
new highway patrol station right in the
conflicted zone considering the fact
that the original writers directors and
cast are all on board the sequel should
be well worth the wait
that's a funny mail is it Jim and I
explore the dark side of celebrity in
the trailer for Gemini the movie stars
Lola Kirk as Jill and assistant to a
Hollywood starlet named Heather played
by zoe kravitz when Heather is murdered
Jill learns she's a suspect causing her
to reevaluate her own views of
friendship truth and fame the trailer
hints that there could be more to
Heather's murder than meets the eye
raising a whole bunch of questions to be
answered in the film with already
stellar reviews from its film festival
premieres Gemini is a stylish murder
mystery we're looking forward to
figuring out the death of Stalin veep
creator Armando Iannucci is about to
satirize yet another country's
government judging by the first trailer
for the death of Stalin the movie shows
the mad rush for power after Stalin's
passing with Jeffrey Tambor Steve
Buscemi and Jason Isaacs playing
characters looking to take charge
I said no problem what I meant was no
problem it may not be a game of Thrones
level fight for power but we're
definitely on board to watch this not so
historical comedy thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]